[Music]
so we're here for you to launch a new
vodka which is weird to me because I
just don't picture you and like alcohol
is that right Wow have you been in a
coma the last few years or yes Blake
loves his booze so much so that the
country singer is an ambassador for the
new brand Smith works vodka
it's from where I'm from I like vodka so
this is like you know that's a
no-brainer for me right peaty sat down
with him to talk about the partnership
but of course we also had to catch up
with Blake about the new season of the
voice you have a very special mentor yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah very pretty girl she
is when when Stefan is is my mentor this
season it's awesome to have her as a
mentor because you talk about an
absolute legend legendary musical icon
and somebody who's been a coach on that
show you know and it was the easiest ask
ever anyways like it's like a lot of it
I looked at my phone and they say you
know there's like somebody from NBC said
hey you need to pick a mentor for this
season and I went like duh I go hey you
don't be my mentor this season she's not
sure okay Quinn said she'll did that's
kind of really doesn't it I thought
maybe it was the horse that you gave her
I did I gave her the horse actually got
her horse and I got my self a horse at
the same time because oh when she loves
riding and she loves horses well you
really want to be seeing a honeybee with
this big tall man and I know you're
planning a win again I'm sure well I'm
sure you've already told us well that
hard me to do is win that show
[Music]